wir sind zurück und haben eine sehr
harte these für Sie die lautet nämlich
Deutschland verblödet ich bin sehr
gespannt
habe ich nicht gesagt wir haben es denn
gesagt
die bildungsnation Deutschland die
ehemalige bildungsnation Deutschland ist
im Freien Erfolg
das Volk der Dichter und Denker fast wie
verblödet ein bisschen höflicher
aber unpädagogisch hätte ich zu meinen
Schülern nie gesagt ja außerdem es gibt
keine dummen Schüler sondern es gibt nur
einseitig begabte es gibt auch keine
Frauen Schüler sondern nur demotivierte
es gibt keine verhaltensgestörte Kinder
sondern nur sozial herausfordernde und
Verhaltens kreative also man kann das
alles schön ummantel ja also die
bildungsnation ist im freien Fall und
jetzt
normalerweise halte ich darüber 90
Minuten Vorträge
ich versuche es mal in 90 Sekunden
hinzukriegen wenn ich so viel Krieg wir
haben totale Schieflagen
hier den großen Stand Standortvorteil
über Jahrzehnte hinweg berufliche
Bildung
qualified made in Germany dort die
akademische Bildung
das ist aus dem Lot geraten wir haben im
Moment
2021 jüngste Zahl doppelt so viel
Student Studienanfänger wie vor 25
Jahren wir haben seit zehn Jahren mehr
Studienanfänger als junge Leute die mir
eine berufliche Ausbildung anfangen wir
haben in Deutschland 18.000
Studienordnungen und 300
berufsbildungsordnungen da ist einfach
was schief wir steuern in eine
pseudoakademisierung hinein und es
fehlen uns Fachkräfte im Bereich der
beruflichen Bildung da braucht man sich
dann nicht zu wundern ich nehme jetzt
mal die jüngste
schulleistungsstudie in dem Fall bezogen
auf zehnjährige auf Grundschüler her da
braucht man sich nicht zu wundern wenn
hier das Niveau und da fängt der Bildung
erst so richtig an dann in die
weiterführende Schule hinein da braucht
man nicht zu wundern dass wir im
Grundschulbereich seit 20 mindestens 20
Jahren bereits zurückfallen und da
stinkt es mir sage ich jetzt mal ganz
deftig wenn man sich dann Seiten sehr
cooles mit der Konferenz oder der
Bundesbildungsministerin den Sound
Bildung ja Gott sei Dank sowieso nichts
zu sagen hat hinstellt und sagt Corona
zu tun okay natürlich hat Corona weh
getan und wenn einem 10 oder 12-jährigen
innerhalb von zwei Jahren oder
zweieinhalb Jahren Corona 500 600 700
Stunden Präsenzunterricht nicht
unterrichtet werden dann kann ich das
auch nicht mit Fernunterricht und mit
Laptop Unterricht und so weiter gut
machen vor allem bei den Jungen nicht ja
also es fehlt von daher
grundschulstudie nochmal jetzt begründet
mit Abfall durch Corona wir wissen seit
den Nullerjahren dass unsere
Grundschulen zurückfallen weil die
Leistungsansprüche runtergefahren werden
Migrantenanteil immer größer wird nehmen
wir mal das Beispiel
Leistungsanspruch wie finden sie es denn
das in Grundschulen der Noten
abgeschafft werden sollen oder sogar
falsch ich halte es für richtig was die
meisten Bundesländer praktizieren das in
den ersten beiden Jahren ist noch keine
ziffernoten gibt aber ich bin dafür dass
dann achtjährige neunjährige schon
langsam auch an solche Maßstäbe behutsam
herange geführt werden ja ich bin auch
dafür dass sie wirklich
geprüft werden dass sie auch mal eine
Seite Text schreiben müssen und nicht
eine multiple choice-test in Deutsch
ausfüllen oder
textstöpseln ja und so weiter
gleichzeitig lügen wir uns in die Tasche
in dem die Noten immer besser werden die
Leistungen werden schwächer und die
Abiturnoten werden immer besser übrigens
alle meine Bundesländer auch in meinem
Bundesland so dass ich mittlerweile das
weiße Liebe Professor wahrscheinlich
besser zu beurteilen wenn ich mir
anschaue das Video Universitäten für
Studienanfänger liftkurse machen ja dass
ich als einerseits nochmal der 22
Abiturjahrgänge 87
[Gelächter]
zum Abitur geführt hat mittlerweile auch
mit Blick auf meine eigenen Leute
die ich zu betreuen hatte und zu führen
hatte mittlerweile Unterschieden
unterscheidet zwischen
studierberechtigung und studiere
Befähigung da lügen wir uns in die
Tasche wir geben ungedeckte Schecks aus
und betrügen eigentlich mit tollen Noten
und tollen Zeugnissen die jungen Leute
ich wusste dass du jetzt mich ich wusste
genau du denkst bestimmt was hat dich
getroffen bei diesem fehlenden
Schulsystem was haben Sie denn für
Abitur haben sie gedient wissen Sie dass
ich Abitur habe aber mein Durchschnitt
sage ich ja nicht weil sie denn einen
Ohren macht das will ich nicht zum Guten
jetzt fragt eine Frage
meine Frage war ehrlich gesagt darauf
bezogen nee ich habe mir ich habe
ehrlich gesagt gedacht gar nicht so
schlecht
mit dieser Angst vor Noten hatten Sie
denn beispielsweise jemals Angst vor
Noten also ich sagte etwas meine
Schulzeit war nicht die schlimmste Zeit
überhaupt ich habe auch das Gefühl dass
ich in der Schule eigentlich nichts
gelernt habe und da wäre ich sogar bei
ihm weil ich auch glaube dass das so die
meisten Sachen die ich so gelernt habe
Schule mir heute nichts gebracht haben
und ich glaube auch dass heute fehlende
Bildung auch kommt daher weil natürlich
auch so ein bisschen also ich spüre dass
in meinem Umfeld auf bei jüngeren Leuten
das auch meistens die Eltern ich bin zum
Beispiel ich komme aus einer Familie da
wurde Bildung war Standard also auch in
die Oper gehen und lesen und ich meine
es gibt heute Leute die alten Wagner für
eine für eine Pizza aber das ist ein
Komponist also ich meine das wird
immer schwieriger alles und ich glaube
das ist schon wahr aber ich muss auch
dazu sagen dass ihr auch glaube wenn man
so ein bisschen wenn ich überlege was
ich so in der Schule hatte was ich da so
gelernt habe was ich dann wirklich
gebraucht aber ich glaube da braucht es
auch ein bisschen Reform dass wir ein
bisschen was anderes machen aber ich
glaube auch und da stimme ich Ihnen auch
zu das Problem ist natürlich auch dieser
Fachkräftemangel den wir ja überall
feststellen kommt auch dadurch durch
diese das Sport also schwierig wieder
Akita Akademisierung
ja das ist also das kann ich habe ich
sogar verstanden und jetzt wird nicht
gelacht drüber ich sehe schon du denkst
wieder ich habe das nicht verstanden
doch ich habe so stark nein
wie war definitiv
schuld an dieser Verdummung als
Medienwissenschaftler das halte ich für
einen naive these die wird zwar gerne
genutzt und ich bin ja auch wie Sie
wissen gerne immer bereit in auch
Mitschuld an irgendwelchen
betrauernswerten Zustände in unserem
Land zu geben aber gerade in dem
Zusammenhang sehe ich das nicht also
diese Vorstellung dass viel Fernsehen
oder was auch immer oder ständig im
Internet sein dass das die Leute
verblödet ich glaube das ist eine längst
überholte Vorstellung im Gegenteil also
gerade die digitalisierten Medien also
die Idee internetbasierten die
computergestützten Medien sind
fantastische Möglichkeiten die ich jeden
Tag nutze die meine Kinder tagtäglich
nutzen und man kann sich das Leben
gerade auch ein intellektuelles Leben
ohne diese Medien gar nicht mehr
vorstellen und selbst im Fernsehen gibt
es vernünftige Sendungen man muss
versuchen aber es gibt sie also ja es
gibt solche selben aber der der ich
glaube das Problem dass Chaos benannt
hat das kann man wirklich sehr sehr gut
ausdifferenzieren denn es ist einerseits
richtig dass durch die Absenkung der
Standards die natürlich auch Gründe
haben also man will nicht auch zugeben
dass es unendlich viele Leute gibt also
ich Populist Politiker genau das ist
also das muss man zugeben dass das hat
auch seine seine Hintergründe aber diese
Absenkung der Standards hat natürlich
eine verheerende Auswirkung es darf
keine dummen mehr geben das darf kein
dumm mehr geben und da spielen die Noten
jetzt eine Schlüsselrolle also natürlich
das viel zu gute Noten gegeben werden
auch bei uns in der Uni ist auch ein
Riesenproblem aber das überhaupt keine
Noten gegeben werden ist deshalb eine
Katastrophe weil die Note die einzig
realistische Information ist die ein
Schüler über seine Leistungen kriegen
kann nicht also dass da drumherum zu
reden und da irgendwie das schön zu
reden ist eine Strafe für die Kinder
selber also man tut denen nichts Gutes
wenn man glaubt sobald man ihnen eine
Sex gibt kriegen sie eine schwere
psychische Störung überhaupt glaube ich
ist das eines der
grundmissverständnisse im Umgang mit
Kindern und auch jungen Leuten dass man
denkt die werden ständig traumatisiert
wenn man sie mal kritisiert oder wenn
man sie darauf hinweist dass sie was
falsch machen ganz im gegen